good day my name is sharon gagan and i'm
a pathologist at stanford university
school of medicine and our topic today
is what is best practice for testing for
unexpected pregnancy in pediatric and
adult patients prior to cancer
diagnostics imaging and therapy
and before we get going i'd like to
disclose that there's several uh
companies listed and as one of the
faculty members at stanford university
i'm required to make this disclosure
before i speak
uh i do not believe there's any industry
sponsored research that i'm citing if
there is i will say it is industry
sponsored otherwise it can be assumed to
be independent
so today our learning objectives are
the following we're going to identify
sample types test types and performance
locations of available human chorionic
anatotropin tests for unexpected
pregnancies in cancer patients will
describe the fundamental rationale
for home uh
hcg tests and precautions regarding
their use
and then we'll compare and contrast
performance characteristics of available
urine and serum hcg tests for diagnosis
of pregnancy and what the clinical
impact is of these differences
we'll detail how erroneous urine hcg
results can occur
and hopefully at the end you'll be able
to design and implement a testing
guideline for testing female cancer
patients for unexpected pregnancy
at your clinical setting
so
all of this really relies on a
commitment to improving the efficiency
and effectiveness of all aspects of
healthcare
based on more accurate and rapid
decision making and for me this involves
looking at laboratory tests and trying
to choose the right test
on the right patient the right sample at
the right time
so let's define the problem we know that
cancer patients are sexually active and
female cancer patients are often in the
reproductive years of their life
yet they face a variety of procedures
both diagnostic and therapeutic which
pose teratogenic hazards
if there's an unexpected pregnancy
and there's
substantial knowledge gaps amongst
health care providers such as physicians
and nurses regarding what the
limitations are of the different tests
and the different sample types
so why do we test well if we know that
diagnostic and therapeutic procedures
pose hazard to an unexpected pregnancy
and yet they're required for cancer
diagnosis and treatment why do we test
well
women are tested for pregnancy so that
decision making regarding pregnancy and
the need for cancer treatment can be
made prospectively
to avoid or minimize potential
hypergenic harm when it's possible
and to avoid emotional distress for the
patient as well as liability for the
physician
and
doing this is patient-centered care and
allows for informed decisions by the
patient and these decisions are the
patients
so some of the interventions we're
talking about that are typically
contraindicated in the pregnancy of
the presence of a pregnancy
yet may be required for the diagnosis
and treatment of cancer include of
course ionizing radiation diagnostic
biopsy and surgical resection procedures
which also
often require anesthesia or sedation
chemotherapeutic agents of course
category x medications which are known
to be teratogenic and nuclear medicine
scans to name a few
so at this point i'd like to
take a quick poll of the audience and
ask the following question
and then i'll wait for your responses
and i will share
the results of the poll
so do you perform a pregnancy test on
your patients before therapy
okay um
it looks like folks aren't going to
answer this one
so i didn't have uh
any results to report oh we did get one
so i'll share that with you
and the person who answered
did answer that they do not
test for pregnancy
so
moving on
ideally we're going to look
at the patient and the patient brings a
question in this case
are they possibly pregnant or not we'll
make a decision and the test will help
us to take an action or an outcome
and based on that principle let's just
look for a minute at the synthesis
of beta hcg so we know that it's
synthesized by the placenta it maintains
the corpus luteum which uh secretes
progesterone and the levels consistently
increase in early pregnancy
and then they drop
so
based on that we want to choose the
right test at the right time
so let's start with the idea of analytic
time versus therapeutic time so when we
talk about analytic time for testing
that includes obtaining the specimen
transporting the specimen and obtaining
the test results
therapeutic time on the other hand
begins with the order from the physician
and ends when a therapeutic action is
taken based on the test result
so we often think of point of care
testing as a good option
for reducing turnaround time
let's give an example here so when we
use a handheld point of care analyzer
such as the istat
in the radiology suite it has become
is to support the standard of practice
which is to review a creatinine prior to
contrast injection
in this case
a creatinine done in the laboratory
takes too much time and it would hold up
patients from going through the mri or
the ct scan
which requires good patient throughput
in terms of paying back the return on
investment
if the creatinine is elevated a more
expensive contrast medium is used to
minimize risk of further
kidney damage and fibrosis due to uh
contrast medium
but inevitably not all patients come
with their creatinine in hand and so for
the unscheduled uh
scan due to an emergency or a sudden
deterioration in the patient these
unexpected studies require creatinine
which is not available uh from the
laboratory in a adequate turnaround time
therefore the point of care creatinine
is available so this optimizes patient
throughput through the scans and it
provides a very excellent cost benefit
so now going back to our
predicament of patients appearing for
cancer treatment or diagnostics in their
reproductive years who may be pregnant
let's look at what we have as options we
have two types of test sample either
urine or serum and that to a large
degree determines where the test is
going to be performed so the urine
requires patient to produce the urine
and collect the urine and although that
sounds very simple those of us who have
waited for uh a urine sample know that
actually it takes a lot longer than you
might think
um there's possible delays therefore
from that um aspect and then this
specimen can be tested either at home or
at the point of care
whereas serum for serum tests blood can
be collected readily but does require an
available phlebotomist so you can't have
a delay there
but the serum must be separated from
whole blood um in the laboratory prior
to testing so
um non-laboratory personnel
cannot separate
whole blood into serum which is the
specimen
required for
for that type of testing that's done in
the laboratory
so what about testing time when do we
test well there's various protocols some
individuals are tested the same day and
others are tested sometime is a pre-op
visit
usually within 10 days or 14 days before
the procedure
so this study i think very nicely showed
what is the impact of testing the same
day versus in the two weeks prior to the
procedure or the intervention
so they looked at this and they were
looking at the incidence of ludial phase
very early pregnancies in which
conception occurs before
the plan procedure which in this case
was laparoscopic sterilization they
retrospectically
retrospectively reviewed
their cases for so-called sterilization
failures in other words the individual
underwent tubal ligation
for sterilization purposes
and
yet they had a pregnancy and this was
after there was a negative urine hcg
test done within two weeks
prior to their um procedure
preoperatively
in these cases they found a rate of
seven in 401 cases there were seven
unexpected pregnancies which is a rate
of about 17 per thousand
when they instituted same-day pregnancy
testing also using urine hcg tests so
they were comparing apples to apples
they found eight pregnancies and were
able to cancel the procedure
um in those eight pregnancies out of 605
which is a rate of 13 per thousand uh
pregnancies
and this was
all of these cases were
followed by followed following a
negative urine
pregnancy test within two weeks so the
same day
um testing picked up an additional um
number which was significant eight out
of um 605 so basically what they said
was they looked at last day of the
menstrual period they looked at
ultrasound records and date of delivery
and so forth and they determine the time
of conception for these cases and the
false negatives um that were um
that occurred when the testing was done
within the two weeks prior to the
procedure
the date
of the pregnancy was determined to be
between 18 and 39 days from the last
menstrual period
so
given on the sensitivity of urine tests
really the the a couple of those
certainly the 39 day pregnancy should
have been
discovered even though the test was not
done the same day of the procedure
however there's a known risk of false
negative
pregnancy tests with urine tests which
we'll describe in a little more detail
later
for the others um
they were a little too early
for the positive pregnancy test prior to
the day of surgery
so
let's talk for a minute about what it
means to have a positive pregnancy test
in a cancer patient if the test is being
done by the lab which is separate from
where the location of the patient is
or if the test is being done at the
bedside as a point of care test in
either case it really represents a
critical value though it often is not on
the critical value list for an
institution so what is a critical value
well the concept of critical value was
introduced several decades ago and it
was defined as
a certain derangement pathophysiological
derangement of such variants with normal
as to be life-threatening if therapy is
not instituted immediately and it has
basically grown from that original
definition to include
results which for which immediate action
must be taken and therefore critical
values must include a physician
notification so it can't just be
electronically
um available it has to be
notified
directly to a physician and that's a
standard of practice today in laboratory
medicine so a critical value
of a pro positive pregnancy test for
chemotherapy patients that are female is
certainly worthy of immediate action
because we know that administration of
chemotherapy to the fetus has
potentially irreversible and damaging
effects depending on what the agent is
so
i'm just highlighting that because
it's very important that a positive
pregnancy test be communicated
immediately
to the
health care take
providers
so
future directions for laboratory
medicine we may be able to determine
that this needs to be a critical value
report and use outcome-based evidence to
define all of our best practices in
critical value testing and report for
special groups of patients such as
cancer patients because obviously a
pregnancy test is not a critical value
in other types of patients
but we can use our clinical informatics
in the future
use tools to support specialized care so
that it would be recognized that this is
a cancer patient in the day hospital
where chemotherapy is given and that a
positive pregnancy test should be called
so that's just a note for the future as
we develop our clinical informatics
tools
so what about home testing many patients
that we see now um have done home
testing are doing home testing
so what's the rationale there well the
usfda which regulates all of this states
that home tests can help detect
possible health conditions
even when you have no symptoms so that
you can get treatment and
specific conditions that they mentioned
where there are no signs where you can
take immediate action is pregnancy
testing perhaps you won't take
medications or take recreational drugs
or
alcohol um if you know that you are
pregnant and it can also help monitor
conditions that require frequent changes
of treatment blood sugar monitoring
diabetics has been a great success story
yet there are provisions that
um
that this can
be that home test must be used with
precautions so that you shouldn't
replace visits to your doctor with home
tests you should talk about your test
results with your physician and the
physician can best evaluate them in
combination with your medical history
and so forth and
and so these are the cautionary notes
that the fda
points out in terms of home testing so
pregnancy home testing is considered
a no-brainer essentially and yet our
testing rationale in in the point of
care arena
is that the influence of training and
competency assessment really impacts
laboratory testing more generally both
the performance and the outcome
so
i would like to cite this study that was
done of over 600 lay women who are doing
um
home kit
pregnancy testing and what it showed
about um about home testing and um some
of the perils
so
basically the age of the women were over
the reproductive years and you can see
there were three age groups from 14 to
24 25 to 39 and 40 to 49 years of age
and they represented
they wanted it to reflect
the study population to reflect the
general population so
they had urban um
urban patients rural patients both
professional and non-professional
various degrees of education so i'd like
you to
look at this
distribution and think to yourself who
do you think is going to do best at home
testing is it going to be the young
folks from 14 to 24 or would it be the
more mature individuals in their 40s
would it be professionals
that would be better at this folks from
rural areas what do you think and then
i'll i'll show you
what was found
so first of all
this is kind of a
detailed chart but basically what i'd
like you to see is that there were 27
kits on the market for pregnancy testing
and only those that had excellent
sensitivity like 100 percent
and specificity
were chosen so if you look at these
results which were done by laboratory
clinical laboratory technologists that
are licensed
they wanted to see
they wanted to basically give our study
participants the best chance to do well
so they only took 11 of the kids that
performed
very very well in the hands of
licensed technology
chemistry technologists so that being
said they went on and they looked at how
many have a high dose hook effect now
hook effect is really remarkable um when
you see a very pregnant individual
that's clearly pregnant and yet they
have a negative pregnancy test why does
that happen well these tests are based
on a certain amount of
of reagent and in very very high hcg
levels
you can see
that
um despite the very high levels here
over 40 or over 30 000
um there are some negative tests some
negative pregnancy tests and that is
known as a high dose hook effect where
basically the amount
of the analyte
overwhelms the test system and so it's
uh it actually does not give you um the
correct response because of the
extraordinary excess of the um analyte
that's being looked for
so
so you could see that a number of the
kits
suffered from a high-dose hook effect in
other words giving a negative test
despite a large degree of um
of hgg being
present
so now let's look at the sensitivity and
specificity um in these uh kits
tested by the 600 oddly women so they
would test it at two different levels so
the um
the first
i'll get my pointer here the first
column here is
uh
you see here
uh the first column here is at twice the
manufacturer's detection level and you
can see in this column the sensitivity
in other words how many um truly
positive at twice the detection level
hcg samples were actually
um tested
positive
only one kit was a hundred percent and
only i think about three were over
ninety percent in this leftmost column
um which is
really surprisingly poor
at the manufacturer's detection limit
limit which is you plus here on the
right
the performance was of course worse
because this is more at the detection
level there was only uh i think two
of the kits that tested
over 90
sensitive so
so this is very concerning and now when
we get to our next slide
um
we'll look at what was the influence of
socioeconomic factors on the
participants on false negative results
so of course false negative results is
what we don't want it's where the test
says that there is no pregnancy but in
fact there is well the false negative
results by age were 39 35 and 36 percent
so extraordinarily high well into the
30s uh real pregnancies being diagnosed
as false negative despite the age of the
um individual doing the testing
professional activity moving down this
chart
was
not important at all whether it was yes
or no
there was a similar
almost identical false negative result
of 36 37
and lastly academic training and degree
of education again was not statistically
significant and the false negatives um
were again very very high
so this would essentially mean that an
individual would go ahead and take their
medication
or you know
take alcohol or whatever the um
the item might be that would not be um
suggested in the in the setting of
pregnancy
yet i don't want to um give the
the idea that in fact
that home testing is not recommended i'm
actually very supportive of home testing
i think that the manufacturer's
instructions and the patient
performance are key and i'd like to just
highlight in contrast to those data i
just showed you that in the arena of
home prothrombin testing and inr
monitoring on patients with coumadin
there have been several multi-center
studies that show patients can perform
as well as professional um with
point-of-care home testing for
pro-thrombin time and inr multiple
multi-center studies show that after
just a little bit of training patients
could even correctly um
make dosage changes which you know is is
not in their purview but i think it just
highlights how well they can do and i
have a reference here at the bottom if
this is an area of interest
that does a very nice review and
meta-analysis of all this literature
which
is very exciting because it shows what
patients can do when they have the
proper instructions when they read the
instructions and then they can perform
confidently and they're motivated to do
so
so let's go back to our pregnancy
testing so there are a number of
operational issues so point of care
testing of urine is often favored
because it can be performed outside the
clinical laboratory and it's it's uh got
a very uh
fast turnaround times it doesn't require
any processing it doesn't require
transport it's just done at the bedside
but it has a higher false negative rate
than serum tests
so
if you're going to opt for the serum
test you have to build it into your
workflow and it has to be taken into
account in scheduling procedures
whole blood point of care
testing are on the horizon
that will allow you the sensitivity you
want
like a serum hcg test but there's no
processing of the blood it can just be
done on whole blood much like a glucose
meter these are not yet commercially
available in the united states but
several vendors have developed them and
will soon be available so what this will
offer once again is a point of care test
on whole blood
that can be done
with a fast turnaround time and
very excellent sensitivity at the
bedside so that's something to look
forward to probably in the new year
so
this may be a bit technical
but i do have references if people are
interested on on the analytic
sensitivities which differ
between urine and blood hcg tests and
they differ to the point where the
qualitative or urine
hcg tests will not determine a pregnancy
and yet the quantitative serum test
which is done in the lab will reveal a
pregnancy uh three to five or even more
days prior to the urine test so there is
a window and this is a window of concern
where the qualitative test which is less
sensitive will not determine a pregnancy
but if one sends it to the laboratory
for a serum test it will have a positive
pregnancy test how often is this an
issue we don't have good data in cancer
population which is our population of
interest in this discussion we do have
some
studies that have looked at um
all you know all
uh individuals having a pregnancy test
and they found to be almost about four
percent of patients
um test in this suboptimal zone where um
the urine
hcg may not detect it um and even the
serum hcg might be low so it is a
significant number of patients that fall
in this suboptimal performance zone
why do we have erroneous um urine hcg
results well the um pearl is that
one should always ask for the first
um urine of the day because that's the
most concentrated but in reality that
often is not the sample that's being
tested so you have hydration you have
dilution issues and so
for that reason you have a
possibility of a false negative in one
emergency department study again not
cancer patients but
there's a limited literature here to
review
there was about a half of a percent of
urine pregnancy results in error they
were due oftentimes to documentation
errors because much of this point of
care testing is actually done with
manual documentation
which i'll talk about in a minute
there was also insufficient sample
issues again making urine is not as easy
in
these types of settings as one would
think
there was also performing personnel that
do incorrect reading time there's a very
particular specified reading time and if
people are multitasking
doing other things distracted or
whatever they may not read the point of
care test at the correct time and
there's we've talked a little bit about
hook effect and interferences
so
there's a concept called therapeutic
yield now in this case a serum hcg is
more expensive
and takes
more time than a urine hcg
but one way to look at this is that how
many times
do you have to do a test
and how many times does that measured
result
result in
therapeutic changes and you divide that
by the total number of time you do tests
and this is a utilization metric so in
other words you do an albumin test a lot
they're done every day on patients
unfortunately sometimes more than once a
day as part of chemistry panels but it's
been shown in the literature that you
rarely change any action whatsoever
based on an albumen test whereas here
we're dealing with a pregnancy test
for which a positive pregnancy
result would definitely
make for changes in um in therapeutic
actions or
or delays
in those actions um so in this case i
think if you look at the therapeutic
yield you'd only be doing a test the
once but you'd be um
definitely
acting on it were positive so this is
just
a way of showing the value of a serum
quantitative hcg
and just while i'm on that subject there
are misconceptions about these tests um
for example it's often quoted that
there's a 48 hour doubling time if
there's a healthy pregnancy on board for
beta hcg but that's been studied further
and much of this whole literature
actually including the graphs that i i
showed you
is based on previous formulations
and there's a wh o standard um that is
now um the tests are being calibrated
against and in in much of the past
literature it was a different standard
we're now on like third generation of
that standard so this is a problem when
you're comparing
old papers and old data with current
data and current tests
because it actually is a different
formulation so that being said
this issue of doubling time for healthy
pregnancies has been studied more
recently and the lower limits of normal
are established where beta-hcg
may increase only 24
in 24 hours and only 53 rise in 48 hours
that's the lower limit of normal so it's
quite different actually than um
then is often quoted
so what about clinical informatics what
can we do about this documentation
issues if we are going to do
point-of-care testing it was shown that
i believe it was a quarter of the
results were incorrect because of
documentation issues in that ed study
what i developed
in my point of care department
over a period of time was a way to
to have nurses document point of care
testing and it was put into the nursing
module the nursing notes module um
it was a nursing documentation um
software and what they could do is they
could choose as you see on the left
point of care testing and click on it
and then the point of care testing menu
would come up and this again was not in
the lab menu because they're not
clinical laboratory technologists
they're charting in a different uh
module entirely of the electronic
medical record and here's another
example where you're looking at doing a
protein urine dipstick you click on
point of care testing and you click over
on the right and it gives you a drop
down menu and you can see that they can
choose what they've seen on the dipstick
and click negative or positive or
whatever um the the result is
another type of test more akin to
looking at a pregnancy test is the
amnesia test
for ruptured membranes and this i'm just
showing you because this is what it
looks like to the operator and then
built into the nursing module they click
on point of care testing they find the
amnesty test and it is a drop down menu
that says was it positive was it
negative uh was the control working and
the beauty of this is that it's
retrievable in the electronic medical
record the documentation is easy to find
it's done um at you know right as the
test is being done and
it allows
for a more standardized um and
complete medical record
so
now we've talked a little bit about some
of the different issues with the testing
but what really is best practice can we
say what best practice is well i'd like
to show you two studies um there's no
published literature in the u.s about
what
people are actually doing
but there are two studies published one
from australia one from ireland so the
australian study demonstrates very
inconsistent practices of pre-operative
assessment of pregnancy status in
hospitals performing in this case it was
surgery which could potentially result
in adverse incidents for the um
pregnancy so 68 of these respondents
said um that they had guidelines for
pre-operative pregnancy testing 55
percent said all women are tested every
any one of reproduction age and 33
percent said that they had
seen patients who had presented for
surgery unaware that they were pregnant
and um
generally about three-quarters felt that
all women of reproductive potential
should have routine pre-operative
testing and 89
supported the introduction of national
or statewide
guidelines
um so
um so that was very interesting and from
ireland um
excuse me
from ireland uh a survey of nine
different teaching hospitals in dublin
um looked at um
you know what what practice really is
and um about 20 percent of respondents
had
had had a patient with a false negative
urinary pregnancy test
which was later discovered 35
said that they routinely informed
patients of the need to avoid pregnancy
before surgery um of the gynecologist
but only 14 of the surgical specialists
advise that and so that's certainly
something that can be built in to
a cancer center protocol
is that um
perhaps you know at the time of the
first round of chemotherapy or before it
that um even children and teens who are
sexually active as we know um as well as
adult females um be advised to avoid
pregnancy and have a contraception
discussion on the day of elective
surgery in the irish study um about
eighty percent um determine the last
menstrual period and um and about half
of them asked specifically about the
chance of pregnancy and their
contraception
seventy percent did a urine pregnancy
test and only one percent ordered a
serum hcg
um and some of these folks only
tested selective people based on um
based on their
uh last menstrual period
but
overall 76 supported women having
reproductive
reproductive potential having the
testing and um
and so generally i think these these um
studies were very interesting because it
shows a lot of variability in practice
but a general support for it
so one
um suggestion in the informatics world
has been to write a rule in the order
entry when you um when you are ordering
category x medications which could be
have an adverse outcome
um on a pregnancy on anyone over a
certain age in the state of california
many have chosen an early age like 11 or
and that you would order a test and it
would be automatically fire would fire
when you're ordering this type of
medication
so
um
i'd like to make another poll
and uh the poll that i'd like to do now
is
um question number two i'm going to push
it out and see
what
attendees have to say about do you
choose a urine pregnancy test on your
patients currently or do you choose a
blood test
for unexpected pregnancy in your
patients
so we're collecting answers now
the answers are either yes no or not
sure
and
i'll give another
little bit of time before i close the
poll
okay and
here are results
okay so um
so we had some folks that are not sure
and some others had answered positively
the wording the question probably wasn't
the best but i think that's
you know in my experience um
i really think that that's very typical
because i don't think that it's always
clear to a physician
or a nurse practitioner who the
individuals ordering the test what tests
they're actually getting and what are
the limitations of that test and i truly
think that as a pathologist that's
something we need to do better with
about with
is truly
educating folks about what they're
getting what are the false negative
rates and so forth so
i just want to um sum up and then
hopefully we can go to some question and
answer period i'd really like to hear
from the audience
first of all we know that serum
pregnancy tests have been systematically
demonstrated to have greater analytic
and clinical sensitivity and they are
associated with reduction in false
negative pregnancy tests in multiple
independent investigations um urine
pregnancy tests are unreliable in early
pregnancy to variable concentrations of
urine and variable hydration status in
the patients
as well as some interferences we talked
a little bit about
about
the high-dose hook effect we talked
about manual documentation issues that
make it hard for the pregnancy status to
be known by all the individuals taking
care of the patient
and so the role of the laboratory is
really to ensure that quantitative
reliable hcg tests are available in a
timely fashion for clinical decision
making
if they're ordered
from the laboratory what i think is
really exciting is that in the united
states
within the next year we're going to see
whole blood hcg point of care tests that
won't require being sent to a lab that
won't require processing and it will
offer excellent sensitivity combined
with expedited turnaround times and i
have abstracts i'm on the point of care
testing
resource committee for the american
association of clinical chemistry and we
had some nice abstracts um if anyone's
interested i'd be happy to send them um
in our recent annual meeting
that showed very nice performance
characteristics of some of these new um
this new r d that has allowed us to uh
to look forward to a better test at the
point of care
so we know that healthcare personnel are
concerned we have the surveys from uh
overseas about unexpected pregnancy in
female cancer patients of reproductive
age
but there is lack of knowledge and
confusion
about the limitations and appropriate
use of urine and serum hcg tests
uh there's clearly variability in
testing practice evident in what is a
limited um published literature and we
don't have the establishment of practice
guidelines
we know that manufacturers are
responsible for provision of improved
labeling and package instructions for
home test kits which certainly have a
place in the medical home
and pathologists serve to educate and
inform the accountable parties
in healthcare settings i think we should
consider professional society consensus
practice guidelines and um i hope to
hear from you
now with a question and answer period
and
moving ahead i think we
can all reduce the risk of iotrogenic
harm
additional emotional stress for cancer
patients
due to undetected pregnancies that
they weren't informed about
and also reduce physician liability by
using the right test
on the right sample at the right time
which in many cases is going to be for
now quantitative hcg
on a serum sample prior to the important
diagnostic procedures and therapeutics
ideally same-day testing if that can't
be done certainly a urine test
is certainly better than no testing at
all and it's our responsibility to all
develop best practices um to help
protect patient safety
thank you
i'd like to invite your questions now
we don't have a question right now so i
have one more question for you
let's see
trying to pull it up now
okay i've pushed out the last poll
question for you folks
and i'd like to hear
it's open now for your answer
the question is does your clinical
setting have a written policy on testing
female patients for unexpected pregnancy
before procedures or therapy
and uh
i appreciate
anyone who's um in the audience to go
ahead and answer
okay
so it looks like we have
some folks answering
so
this was a question to just assess
um if
the audience members know that they have
a policy or whether they perhaps
don't know or
or
just to get a sense of
what's out there because
there really isn't any literature
published from the u.s at this point in
time
okay so i've closed the poll
and
now i'm pushing out the results and you
can see them
um we have a not sure and we have a yes
so
just a couple of responses
so once again if there's any questions
i'd be really happy to answer them i'm
going to go to the next and last slide
because i'd like to thank you for
attending today
and if you have any follow-up questions
or you'd like to have any of the
references or
discuss
this issue
i'd really be happy to hear from you at
s-g-e-a-g at stanford.edu
and
i really appreciate your attendance
thank you
you